Modern movie fans are a breed of their own,
but superhero movie fans are even more dedicated.
That means they want to know about every plot
point, character, or twist ending - even the
ones that weren't filmed. They're not all
game-changers, but sometimes, it's the scenes
that DON'T make the cut that sound the most
interesting. Here are Screen Rant's10 Amazing
Superhero Movie Scenes You've Never Seen.
The Dark Knight Rises
Even before fans got to see Heath Ledger's
take on the Joker, the filmmakers knew they
had a star villain. As a result, they came
up with several ways to give the Joker a cameo
in the third and final movie in the trilogy.
When Ledger passed away before the film released,
Christopher Nolan scrapped the plan out of
respect. But the novelization of the movie
contains what was probably the plan, revealing
Joker to be the sole inmate of the new Arkham
Asylum.
Man of Steel
The villains of Zack Snyder's alien title
fight were also expected to get even more
time to shine. In the original script, Zod
was going to arrive to Earth, and drop his
lieutenant Faora into downtown Shanghai, and
the overgrown Nam-Ek into another foreign
capitol. But knowing that Metropolis was going
to be devastated by the Kryptonian forces,
destroying two more cities seemed like overkill.
The Incredible Hulk
In Marvel's first Avengers team-up, Bruce
Banner lets a serious secret drop, admitting
that he had tried to commit suicide to end
his struggle with the Hulk inside of him.
The line is actually a reference to the original
opening of The Hulk's second solo movie, where
Bruce headed to the arctic to end his life
the same way - the kind of opening scene that
would have set a completely different tone
for the rest of the movie.
The Avengers
Easily the best deleted scene from Marvel's
team-up, Captain America was originally going
to be given his own introduction, after his
solo movie led directly to The Avengers. Fans
would have seen how lonely and out of place
he had become, in need of a new mission and
new purpose in the Marvel Universe, not to
mention what would probably have been comic
legend Stan Lee's greatest cameo to date.
Iron Man 3
Iron Man's third outing was as much a comedy
as a superhero movie, but one of the film's
best gags was left on the cutting room floor.
Audiences only get a brief glimpse of the
Miss Chatanooga Christmas Pageant before the
scene cuts to Tony sneaking between firemen
and camera crews into a TV van. What fans
missed was the contestant's clumsy answer
reducing her and the crowd to tears... well,
actually, it was the tear gas Tony was pumping
into the theatre to cause the distraction
he needed.
Man of Steel
Once Krypton's fate is sealed, the Superman
origin story follows his spaceship to America's
heartland, before suddenly jumping decades
into the future. But audiences were originally
going to get to see even more of young Superman,
in a scene that took a baby Kal-El to a doctor's
office for a routine hearing test. The high
pitched sounds caused him to scream and shatter
all the windows in the building, which would
have been good for a laugh, but the tone seemed
too light considering the planet's destruction
in the scene before.
Thor: The Dark World
No Thor fan will forget seeing the god of
thunder's mother, Frigga being killed in the
second solo movie, sacrificing her life to
protect her son's true love and putting up
a serious fight beforehand. But in the original
version, Thor's father Odin was going to be
the one to blame, refusing to hand over the
Aether the Dark Elves were seeking, and ignoring
his wife's pleas to kill her captors. It would
have been a strange choice, but a pointless
one: Odin is removed from the throne by the
end of the movie, anyway.
The Dark Knight Rises
As dark as the movies may have been, Christian
Bale's Batman still had a sense of humor.
Fans would have gotten another gag when he
rescues John Blake, and the detective asks
how he always arrives just in time. He claims
it's because he plants tracking beacons in
all his allies' necks while they sleep, leaving
Blake - and fans - to wonder if it's just
a joke, or an actual explanation for his perfect
timing.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
As soon as the movie hit theaters, Avengers
fans had one question: what was up with Thor
and the pool of water in that cave? In the
original cut of the movie, Thor was actually
possessed by one of the fates, revealing Ultron
to be after the Mind Stone, one of the six
Infinity Stones being gathered for the Infinity
War sequels. Eventually the scene was replaced
with a quick vision, leaving Thor's actions
soon after a bit of a mystery.
Deadpool
The unexpected interest in a Deadpool movie
was mainly due to the script turned in by
Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick, which apparently
included a community of assassins placing
bets on who would be the first of them to
die on the job. Deadpool instead put his money
on Amy Winehouse, with the English singer
constantly shown avoiding death by inches
throughout the movie. Since the singer passed
away in 2011, it's safe to assume the subplot
was removed entirely.
Those are some of our favorite deleted or
scrapped scenes from superhero movies, but
which ones do you know of that we missed?
Be sure to let us know in the comments, and
remember to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.